unbelievable believable I say
unbelievable why can't I be bald
Oh I look exactly alike what makes you
assume that because there's five
customization options yeah and one of
them's Asian and I don't think that
you're gonna take that one bold
assumption mark you're right you know
what I shouldn't assume I apologize Oh
God Bob went all of the other directions
there is always right here hello
Hey and we all look different yeah we
all look very different yeah I didn't
know I could change the color of my
shirt Bob thank you I've pledged my
loyalty to these sire you have to join
the farm I'm trying I didn't see how way
did it so I'm just guessing mark I like
your face get away from me you didn't
see my gusting peasant hold on mark oh
I'm up all right there you go well Bob
I've apparently visited the barn let me
oh it's in German Achtung video vakhtang
look we're gonna buy property 2012 I
bought the land its own to me show my
shirt apparently for growth why do we
need to take our shirts off for growth
it says move our tops for growth oh it
does I don't know shirts off take your
shirts off
wait is this against which terms of
service probably if your IRL naked on
stream than yes unless you don't have
nipples then I think you're okay
well what if my nipples are just below
the camera that's probably fine just
stay low sorry I mean I don't know the
TOS it's they change every day and we
don't we don't keep up
threshold I'm gonna open my shirt and
when my channel gets banned that's when
you know all right clip this so we know
I once you buy some land you'll need a
plow harvester and a seller okay okay
how do we get a plow harvester also if
you hit escape and go to the vehicle
overview maybe or we go your nope the
dollar no railroad silo shop I'm going
on there's a shop over here over here
over here boss Oh mark look what you
found buddy over here boss work I just
I'm down to two viewers after you said
you were getting naked on stream and
everyone left
well maybe done maybe you should have
gotten naked oh we need a small [ __ ]
what kind of small tractor do we want do
we want to no Valtra listen we just need
the cheapest one cheapest one got it but
beyond 1,300 DP fifty nine thousand euro
it's fifty nine thousand euros that's
the cheapest parts of this menu are
called potato technology speech
technology we need beat technology got
the Panther to cost three hundred
seventy five thousand dollars how
expensive my god beats okay no we just
need a basic tire stir and us basic
sower I think so or means planting if we
get a tractor we can pull it behind the
tractor right oh we need to pull it we
need it well we might as well a sport
for the suspension car as the indicate
indicated fruit types week at least we
can lease oh thank God I found the
headers the headers are under the tools
the header is the swoopy swoopy swoosh
apart there's jewels there's tools oh oh
there's a wiener where we have to get
the weeds that grow between the crops -
okay alright we'll get the Weiner we so
we water we weed we harvest
okay okay oh we need the topper okay we
need the $22,000 topper topper because
it says before beets can be harvested
the foliage needs to be cut with a hell
hopper oh okay in between swings we have
to get a cultivator to prepare the field
for the next sowing oh my god farmers
really do know there's no way so let me
get the tractor first let me get the
tractor first 590 per day
oh man that's manager I'm gonna I'm
gonna lease us a tractor okay all right
what does the tractor do compared to all
the other things we've seen a lot of
this equipment it needs to be towed the
tractor is fourth latina we basically
need three tractors one with the
harvesting header one with the trimming
header and one dragging a trailer to put
the beets in well no you have one
tractor you do it in stages but there's
three of us
all right so you want to rent three
tractors so that would be the only
difference right how much could it
possibly cost well sure I'm gonna get
the cheapest small one there is the
little Fiat 300 DT I'm gonna get us
three of them okay all right
we're doing it lease it for three
thousand and nine euros yes can pick
your leased vehicle door baby oh hell oh
my god I love it
what happens if I wrecked into a car do
not wreck it into a car yeah it's a
lease oh you can go first person how do
you do it see I see oh wait guys we
don't have trailer we didn't get the
trailer Oh Oh coming back and
everything's going well and we're
leasing one of those yeah yeah yeah okay
okay
Oh what else do we need to lease I don't
know what these are so I don't know what
you got I got the topper and a harvester
to be towed if you back your tractor up
you can get all attached to them I what
I'm guessing is the harvester come on
come on back
this machine can collect oh no do we
need to lease one of these douche bags
no I press the button never mind you did
it I did it
pipe out ah interesting
damn alright so I'll wrap myself a
trailer and I'll be trailer by it okay
what is Wade Wade has the topper so we
can go do his thing I guess maybe I
don't know is this the topper yeah you
need something again what it tops all
right so I'm gonna be tipper Bob okay so
that's my big bad baby over there uh-huh
and this thing hooks up in the back of
the Franck's this little things supposed
to look up in the front maybe the back
no the back is facing you
squid douche that's it you'll all be
glad I've been playing a lot of American
Truck Simulator lately so I'm very good
at driving with trailers q oh yeah look
at that whoo all right so wait I think
you're supposed to go first yeah go all
right well here we go so Bob you and I
have to synchronize right we do indeed
circuit all right
Oh God well there's cruise control all
right so Oh No why did you stop
why would you signs of apparently I'm
swerving all over I can see that where
are we going going to the I think we
make a right you know oh my god wait no
I know what's the other way take the
roundabout yeah you got it
I'm driving a huge trailer just to be
clear you guys trusted me to look at the
map I glanced I misread it your trailer
it's on the wall oh it's like Oh cuz the
pipes is winged like I thought but the
right men we're getting honked at now
mark in your backswing garden dude see
you guys at the farm
why whoa whoa wait swear to God okay you
detach while you're moving that would be
a not smart yeah don't do
I mean I want to we're neck before you
learn later you know what the hell never
try why don't you just never learned I
don't want to learn
I'll follow Wade's illegal left turn but
you know we're farmers the thing we
bought that I'm using is supposed to be
attached to the front but this tractor
doesn't have a front attachment you'll
just have to drive backwards it's fine
it's fine okay oh yeah cruise controls
the way to live
you guys have cruise control on no
didn't know hit 3 to toggle it on and
then 2 to turn up the speed and one to
turn down the speed I thought I'd talk
to you it's not oh there goes okay I'm
gonna just partner up for a sec boy
Wade's you got it all the crops are gone
oh yeah they're there they're
underground beets or beets a root
vegetable right yeah they're in there
you're cutting off the top weight you're
missing an entire row see you see you
see these grass I didn't see them at
first I see all right well left I will
have to clean this up this is a first
draft yeah dry number one I think we're
doing fine I think we're doing great
hey Mark how's it going hey good are you
I like your tractor friend thanks man
thank you
I'm glad you just parked in the road and
nobody has noticed or done anything
about it
country roads straight go straight
are we following are we following Wade
then yeah I think so here I'll wait till
you get up alongside your harvester
lined up yeah I crushed the crops you're
you're supposed to do that no they're
gone alright that section is topped can
I Drive through this wheat field or is
that gonna hurt things that's not our
field I don't give a [ __ ] I don't have
access to that land
well okay alright chef Wade we're
concentrating
oh wait turn it off I'm not I'm not
under my god you didn't get any of that
I got a little in the wind
look the way at what Meeny this is hard
yeah this is real [ __ ] tough watch
your lane I didn't do that
my harvester was not on okay okay I
think I'm I think that means I'm in
there
I'm not doing anything tell mark he
doesn't name Bob till he's full no we're
fine we're fine this is fine let's do it
mark there's any forest do it alright
here we go I'm going yeah yeah that's it
that's the stuff look at all this beats
me yeah yeah I'm giving it to you am i
blocking you a little bit but it's okay
it's all right wait look we're doing
farm we're farming nice work
oh my god oh my God look at this
machinery my god we're pretty much
killing it right now we're killing it
all right cruise control wait start and
now three two one go there we go
bobby's Oh what
you know what chat was saying you don't
need me until you're full maybe you just
do a pastime let's see how full you get
all right cool I'll just get out and
watch and not destroy any more of our
crop yeah all right I still hate the
fact I'm going backwards I just want to
say for the rahuri up wait wait if you
want to switch I'll do that I've almost
got it down to a science now I'll mark
your ding-a-lings uh rotating to put it
down thank you
oh I've got a full ometer oh I can turn
off crop destruction in settings bro
that sounds like I think oh no guys I
don't know how trailer physics work I've
never driven a truck all right I'm gonna
come over i'ma drop a load all right I'm
coming in Oh Oh bobbins I'm so stuck I
wanna get out of this all right
I got you okay thank you I got you no
wait wait wait wait wait wait to thank
you okay sorry sorry you're right I'm
just let's go there man thank God these
machines are smarter than us
dude can I take a turn at one of these
cool jobs yeah sure here take it
Jesus Christ take it oh these are
potatoes this isn't wheat yeah whatever
okay
here's alright how much really I have no
idea how trailers work oh my god this is
the war you mean are you trying to like
back it up
yeah the trailer physics dive not about
it oh no well you can do what you need
to do but going forward people are
telling me why wouldn't they make
something that you harvest it and then
you attach a trailer behind it like
you're a double decker like in the front
you've got the top I would imagine they
do if you don't buy the cheapest farm
equipment that you can find hey I'm
trying to save us money wait mark just
drove over those crops and he's fine
you're kind of in winter mark I gotta be
honest we're good in the way I was we I
was trying to come up for you but I
guess I'm not welcome here I killed
those crops all these crops on the edge
I'm killing him crops chat I just killed
a bunch of them yeah you can't once
they're topped they're good when they're
not topped they're no good well
apparently there was a vehicle or some
combination we could have gotten where
one vehicle could have done what I'm
doing and what that one's doing at the
same time that's what I just suggested
that's what I just said Obama you would
love to go for it I'm like so down to
you I'm gonna go for it
in there buddy I'm getting in there pal
oh look at that look at the manoeuvre
yeah I think I speed cruise controls on
great keep it going
who's control one oh my goodness physics
are weird yo you could stop you're not
harvesting anything okay you're good I'm
detaching arms swinging down oh we
cleared that perfect picture perfect I'm
25% full we're about to have a payday
friends we got 10,000 beets absolutely
wealthy man you're going to be sloshing
in it well okay Bob we need to talk
because I think that the two of us are
doing more work than one of us is wait
after yeah we should get a half share
okay look out cleanly I'm vacuuming up
your mess wait very actually it's all
perfect hmm there's a bird I'm going for
it get that bird up that's the wrong way
hang on
get back boy did you get that oh my god
wait I think you just
I think you top that bird man whoever
planted these crops for us is really
nice I know I feel like we totally
deserve this though you know we do
obviously we do ok crop destruction is
now off wait you can now drive forward
okay now that I've read learn how to
drive this thing I mean it's just
driving regularly yeah definitely going
forward that does backwards a little bit
more juice in the forward momentum
forward hits different dough I could
drop this off for and sell it and then
come back that might be good alright
where do I sit though wait please I
don't know chat where do we sell it
where do we sell it
Gregory mill to be the consensus I will
go grain mill this is the harvester so I
drove over the crops with this one right
yeah see you drive drive directly over
them and snatch them up oh god did I get
a flat I'm really spinning my wheels
here Oh No
barely oh no I'm stuck what am i stuck
oh there's a car kick are you just
casually crashing into a car like stuck
out of here
go away finally geez you jerk all right
how do I drop this off oh that's a fair
question actually I don't know all right
I'm just gonna it looks like there's a
platform here I'm just gonna go up on
the platform and probably looks like a
scale all right I'm in baby okay I made
it okay I'm gonna detach get out hello
hello no no I think you got to find the
yellow circle like we did when we
released all of our equipment there's no
circle there's got to be a circle oh
wait I was literally one inch not
forward enough I'm low I'm on load and
I'm just pouring it on the ground here
he's raking up look in the top right
that was five thousand money's fine
that's plenty of money you know how many
you know what a beat is it's gross it's
terrible it's we got to grow good stuff
like iPhones okay how do we do that I
don't know like apples grow on trees or
something
Oh what what all right anyway I'm coming
back I guess uh you know five thousand
dollars in a day that's that's good
money you know well we're gonna have
this whole field so that was maybe a
quarter at most of our harvests okay you
know that's you know when you put it
like that you know it's not too bad a
cement truck please dear god stop oh god
oh god oh god okay it's fine yeah I'm
cutting through the Henderson farm
coming straight to you guys I mean
that's true you can't destroy crops so
it's pretty safe yeah yeah yeah it's not
a body is there a body in the field it's
almost definitely there's a body
yeah start rumors about the Henderson's
I like this node oh it's a shadow sorry
it's a shadow sorry I'm coming in you
ready to dump we are at 93% okay Haley
yeah give me all of it wait extend your
arm how do I do that there push the
button it's in the huge list of
instructions in the top-left accept it I
see you love your lift wonders pipe out
myself pop out pipes I'm coming I'm
coming down I'm gonna come in come in
hey
like you just ran me no I didn't I yes
that's how it works
I took damage you damaged three no I
didn't stop being a baby
oh my god there's more damage
no all right there we go they're gone
that's good stuff
Bob did you just give up at the end
there what I'm doing it it's fine
all right what's wrong with this it's
your MD this is it well I mean we can
always get more and then dump more in
there right harvested Mart waits done
like two rows I was full you're full
with two rows we're dumping while you
harvest that I was full of my god all
right wait I'm just gonna Park this here
I guess so like I'm gonna go get a
better whatever you are listen wait I'm
sorry I apologize
I mean I'm 20% of the way through from
one row this thing just doesn't hold a
lot all right here the dumper is there
you can dump I'll go to the shop unless
Bob you want to be the only person who
does the shop stuff oh you you go buy
some stuff my good dude buy some good
useful things for sure
oh I'm froze Olga blam I like I'm I
bought a thing shush your face I don't
think this thing needs a it didn't say
anything about needing um if you bought
a harvester it might need a header Reno
no I didn't it said it didn't need a
header oh okay well then there you go
guys I got the beat o matic a beat
Blaster 9000 beat Annihilator here one
load what oh my god dude I don't have
one
oh I can ride I'm under you buddy all
right cool full bloating vehicle and
folding No
wait guys get out of there okay lower
lowing vehicle
it's a loading this is not a harvester
this is a scooper upper oh of stuff on
the ground when you harvest things that
cut you cut down first no it said it
could dig it out of the ground
I'm glad you spent twenty thousand of
our dollars on that I know she ate it
real fancy like though all right okay
maybe I got the wrong thing it's I bet
you earn it I'm gonna try everyone's
like that Marx's for corn
no it's for hay no it's for sugar boots
it's for beets it's for me I bought it
from the beet thing yeah I think it's
for scooping them up once they're on the
ground
oh no it's for unn topped beets it does
all of it
oh that's unfortunate and all this time
topping them all I don't know how longs
it take beets to grow know how do I sell
huh no no so you're the only one who
sold anything just dump it on the
platform or whatever right that was
beets this is a truck well that's a beet
truck maybe it works the same way I put
it in the building that I leave they'll
take it I guess this the description of
what I bought said this machine can
collect sugar beets from the ground and
tips them into a trailer that's what it
says it do I'm guessing what we need is
just a better tractor then right
everyone's saying marks being mark slow
no that's time that's not a thing that's
definitely a thing I don't know I'm like
mark fast
everyone thinks to like mark Oh mark he
fast that's what they say wait no why is
the top speed only that we know him over
there no no no no no no
oh mama no mama no mama no one that's
like yes yes that's the one well there
was no mark please please show the class
what you've done
gamma no Carmen I'm coming and it's not
as fast as I thought it was gonna be oh
no it just takes a bit to pick up speed
there we go
oh good great I know no baby baby baby
listen to me baby baby get out of our
car Oh God how did that car push me
Oh God why do you keep wrecking all of a
sudden you're the one telling me dude
careful about driving when don't talk to
me ever
all right are we swapping light I'm full
can I dump out real quick yeah yeah look
we can put the topper in the front and
we can put the hopper in the back well
we don't need that topper that's fine
okay look well it was a lease so I put
it in the garage they'll probably take
us should we be replanting or doing
something with the dirt over here
probably need a plan turning sowing
sower machine that's all like do some
with the soil because it still has the
the green it's sweet it's still only ten
it's still only ten oh my god okay what
else
oh no it's just slow ly annoying is I
picked this game mode or our server
because it was all will teach you how to
play farming simulator I don't very
taught if I'm honest can I say then can
I be useful or hmm well I got it that
works you cannot do not listen I'm gonna
hand I need to look at you when I
let me tell you they weren't over here
hang on sorry I worked in work there
work there worked all right look you in
the eye you [ __ ]
all right that's all you have to say to
me
oh I've got more to say okay but pull
your weight where'd your face go Oh like
this over there your face was gone wait
the thing yeah the thing okay whatever
can you unhook the other tractor from
the thing it has and come over here and
pick up we need it we need a tiller and
a plantar's what we need hey Mark do you
wanna go ahead and attach this thing to
your front yeah might as well right this
will be the the repo mattock this will
be the the Grim Reaper you know what I
mean yeah you coulda better position for
me you could alright I'll get it what
are you doing I'm getting it go get out
of here stop looking at me God oh my god
that's what you sound like you're the
worst at farming I got it
alright I'm all set alright uh higher
worker what does that even do I think
you can just hire someone to do the job
you're doing
I hired great I hired someone to do the
job I'm doing there is the red dot
there's a hostile on our farm right now
but I'm also here I don't know what the
benefit is I could just do it myself
what are they doing what what what does
this worker doing what no that's not no
all right oh that's wait what no okay
there give the 15 euro wage payment
that's oh hey another one what know that
you doing I don't know ed but I don't
understand what this workers doing I
were gonna dismiss the worker I just
missed the worker no no you're good
you're doing great man do you've uh
you've been $50,000 very well it's my
money too
of if we divvy up all the money we got
you
a hundred thousand I have six hundred
thousand Bob as three hundred thousand
up wished more spent less wasted less
and destroyed less you destroyed so much
when you were you you know what you just
keep harvesting Bob I'll worry about the
finances and everything else i that bob
was putting up our crops I don't know if
we already need to sell this bag
[Music]